okay I'm torn today between two
lecture topics my plan had been to give
a lecture on the basic overall
circumstances of thinking about the
history of the 20th century and that is
what I'm going to do however this
morning in my reading and they
discovered that knit garments did not
appear in China until the early 20th
century before that time they would cut
cloth and sew it together for socks
had no sweaters and so forth and then
when knit garments came in it had a big
impact upon clothing in China
unlike the sewing machine which did not
because the type of stitch that you had
and a Singer sewing machine was a lock
stitch the Chinese used to chain stitch
and they sewed their garments with much
finer stitching than they got from a
singer machine and the singer machine
was too expensive so unlike other parts
of the world where the export of singer
sewing machines revolutionized the
making of clothing in China this was not
so much the case at least not in
anywhere like the volume and immediacy
of impact that you found elsewhere on
the other hand
the importation of the practice of
knitting did have great impact because
knitting could be done at home you could
sell the products and you had the first
time knit socks in China and by the Oh
Post 1911's of the Revolutionary period
in China you can have things like knit
sweaters or vests and the old padded
quilted winter jacket begins to be
supplanted by by knitted wear which of
course also implies wool which had not
been a major part of the Chinese textile
profile in the in earlier times China
primarily used cotton silk and hemp of a
not wool wool of course implied sheep
and then there's questions where no
sheep blah blah blah so obviously
something that's going to interest me a
great deal more than probably anyone
else in the world and then at lunch I
brought it up with my with my learned
colleagues and we got to the question of
well when did knitting spread elsewhere
like when did knitting come into the
Islamic world from the Middle East and
that got into the issue of wearing socks
for prayer you have to wash your feet so
you have to take your shoes and your
socks off but then you can put the socks
back on of course your socks are not
always the cleanest garments you have
but you put them back on or else you put
them in your pockets with the dirty end
sticking out and so I just trying to
find out if there were any hadith about
the prophet's view of socks or whether
socks come in later on
and the whole question of the world
historical impact of knitted socks
seemed like something that would be
appropriate for the sorts of lectures
that I am inclined to give but I decided
not to and yet there's a link between
that topic and what I am going to
lecture on which is the nature of 20th
century history all of the remaining
chapters in the book deal with the 20th
century and are well actually the
ultimate chapter deals with post
twentieth century but we're not and not
requiring you to read that one and
that's that's a big chunk of a book of
this size and seems to be I suppose in
most people's minds proportional to the
importance of the 20th century in
history and yet when I did a quick count
of the sixteen to seventy people listed
in the Columbia catalog as historians in
the department of history that includes
historians from Barnard and from the
East Asian languages and cultures
Department
I found that approximately half of the
tenured professors here in history I
have written substantially are primarily
on 20th century history and yet in the
world history textbooks if you have say
four chapters out of 36 devoted to the
20th century that's one ninth not 1/2 in
terms of the actual historical
profession then the near past seems to
be too little much in a much more
important fashion than the more distant
past even when the more distant past
let's say is no farther away than 1850
now the one obvious explanation of this
would be that we know what happened
before 1850 but we're still masticating
the 20th century to try and find out
what happened and therefore what goes up
to the late 19th century is kind of a
homogenized given this is what history
is and then what happens since the late
19th century is still up for grabs I
have talked before about my concern
about a premature canonization of world
history along exactly these lines that
people will come away with the idea that
everything is known in a fairly compact
readable form for world history up until
fairly recent times and then we get into
the interesting stuff I've tried to
point out both last year and this year
that this is far from truth that almost
every phase of human history is
summarized in a brief inadequate fashion
in the textbooks that we have on world
history and that there are more stories
more turning points more you know
aspects to look of the history from then
you would ever draw from reading a world
history textbook but those earlier times
no longer attract so many historians now
when I say no longer I'm thinking of the
long of the history of history writing I
mean there was a time for example when
the history of the Roman Empire was
terribly important for a lot of
historians their time talking about the
era of Edward Gibbon in the 18th century
when the notion of something that
happened many centuries before loom died
was important because it was a kind of
model for what could happen you know in
a more proximate future so we get to a
Napoleonic period where the Roman Empire
is actively remembered in styles and
furniture and symbolism as opposed to
the American Republic where it's the
Roman Republic not the empire that is
seen as being sort of at the root of
civility and someone like George
Washington as compared with Cincinnatus
is the great warrior who comes out of a
bucolic background to save Rome and then
goes back to the farm again so there
were times when earlier history was
selectively emphasized and where you
found comparatively little interest in
contemporary history and indeed you had
historians who were perfectly willing to
dispute the fact dispute the the
assertion that things in the recent past
were part of history they were part of
living experience the people who had
participated were still alive one
waiting for their memoirs but history
wasn't wasn't necessarily to be written
about those recent events there are
always some historians who did know who
after the French Revolution write a
history of the French Revolution but
there were others who felt very strongly
that they should the job of the
historian was to study earlier things in
my particular field of Middle Eastern
history
yet it has been it became very very
clear in the 1970s navies in particular
that most of the people who studied the
history of the Middle East did not study
did not think about did not want to be
asked about recent Middle Eastern
affairs if you studied in my field
you're expected to know what happened to
Mohammed on Tuesday and you know in
early November of 611 and then what
happened the day the next day I mean if
we have a work called the Anala del
Aslam the annals of Islam that really
goes on a date by day basis compiled by
the Italian compiler Leonie Kotani and
you it was really felt you needed to
know the 7th century the 17th century
was of no interest but you needed to
know the 7th century so people like me
studied the 7th century
I wrote my senior thesis as an
undergraduate about the life of Muhammad
because after all isn't that where we
all have to start you know to write
about the 20th century however it was
felt that that wasn't the job of a
middle east historian maybe a diplomatic
historian or a historian of European
imperialism but somehow that was outside
our remit I recall in the 1970s a French
diplomat stationed at the UN
who would come over to the Middle East
Institute here and attend brown bags and
seem to be very interested in the the
talks that she heard and I asked her you
know when you're back in Paris you seem
so interested in what the Middle East
speakers are in our series when you're
in Paris who do you talk to among the
Middle East experts to get scholarly
advice on what's going on in Middle East
she said oh we talked to a Maxime wrote
a song I said yeah okay fine
and then who else said only him no
nobody else will talk to us they all
think that everything important in the
Middle East happened hundreds of years
ago and they don't follow Affairs we now
have a new generation of people who are
deeply imbued with the 20th and 19th
centuries of Middle Eastern history but
this is a very recent phenomenon so it
is not axiomatic that the century that
is most proximate to the time that one
someone is teaching or writing is going
to be the one that draws the most
historical attention and yet the 20th
century clearly draws much more
historical attention than any other
period or any other period of history at
the present time so is there something
special about the 20th century that
warrants this or is this just part of
the sociology of the historical
profession why I'd argue it's not the
latter because when you look at books
that are written for the general public
dealing with history you do have
occasional outstanding books that deal
with the period say before 1850 but not
that many whereas we have
a huge number of books that deal with
with recent American history in
particular I have a colleague at a
college in Pennsylvania who was coming
up for tenure and she asked do I need to
have a book written and she was told no
you have to have three articles
published in peer-reviewed journals
because that will show that your
scholarship is this is good she said
well why not a book that's what everyone
else requires they said well you know
anybody can publish a book and everyone
in her department was an American
historian and of course you can
published anything about American
history and have people read it you
don't have to go through a university
press or something so the recent history
is more interesting now than recent
history was I would suggest in 1850 or
1750 or 1650 be happy to debate anyone
on that just not today
so what is it about about the 20th
century in the first place you have many
historians who have fallen into the
habit of talking about either a long or
a short century so you'll have people
say well we'll talk about the long 19th
century that means the history of
everything up until World War one in
1914 and because they'll say well
everything before that is really simply
a kind of unchanging continuum from what
you have in the previous century or two
or you'll have someone who talks about
say the long eighteenth century goes
from say Oh
seventeen thirty up to 1850 or so so the
notion that the the round numbers that
denote a century are always
dominant in the thinking of the
historian that really doesn't hold up
well then neither does this arbitrary
notion that you can simply designate the
length of a century so for example the
long 19th century that goes up to World
War one if you were a Russian
experiencing a revolution in 1905
an Iranian experiencing a revolution in
1906 Turks experiencing revolution in
1908 you might feel that actually the
20th century starting in 1900 was an
important time because it was the the
pre-revolutionary moment so that the the
notion of a long 19th century feeds in
particular into the very the traditional
portrayal of history as being primarily
the history of Europe and it's any of
the outliers elsewhere like the United
States Canada so nevertheless it is a
century I had proposed a one point to
Columbia University Press I've mentioned
this in this class before that I would
edit a history of the 20th century the
Columbia history of the 20th century and
that book was published to no acclaim
and and partly the reason I had no claim
was that it did not have a dominant
narrative thread my premise was what are
the ways in which human life
categorically has changed in the course
of 20th century that sets that century
apart from the earlier centuries and so
I would pick topics like transportation
or communications or popular culture or
socialism scientific discovery and I got
people to to write chapters of sort of
mixed quality on each of those topics
but I never told the story of World War
one I've never told the story of World
War two because I was unwilling to
assume that in the long sweep of things
those would end up being the most
important stories I was thinking in the
sense of trying to write a book or edit
a book that would read well in in 2100
you know that wouldn't look shallow or
biased or no off base from a hundred
years perspective it would not be
overtaken by my historiographical
fashions or ideological or economic
changes in the world
and I don't expect to be around in 2100
to see how well the book holds up I'm
still happy that I carried out the
project but as I look back in the
project and I look at people who work on
20th century history one of the things
that's increasingly evident to me is
that among historians you have a
division between what I would call
stakeholders and non stakeholders
stakeholders are people for whom there
is a consequence to their historical
writing that goes beyond simply the
padding of their bibliography or the
pleasing of their immediate family that
there's a longer-term significance to
thee to the work non stakeholders by
contrast would be people who are
intellectually drawn to the past and to
the myriad ways of studying the past and
the myriad sources of information both
public and arcane that can contribute to
writing a story of something that
happened in the past well that might not
seem to be a hugely important difference
but it came to my mind many years ago
when I was teaching at University of
California Berkeley for a couple of
years and I got to know an eminent
Assyria lodgest named a Leo Oppenheim
Oppenheim was interested in my work on
the history of camel saddles I was
interested in his long long career as
directing the the Chicago Akkadian
dictionary project which was designed to
make available every word in the
Akkadian language with its sources and
meanings and so forth
the project has now been completed
Oppenheim died while I was at Berkeley
and his his one big synthetic work was
called ancient Mesopotamia
and at the in the preface of the work he
says I've named this book ancient
Mesopotamia :
the a portrait of a dead civilization
and he said that it's terribly important
for him to regard ancient Mesopotamia as
being dead that there is no remnant of
it there are no Akkadian speakers left
there are no Sumerian speakers left
nobody writes in the cuneiform script
that was used at that time all of the
cities are in ruins
the memories are are all gone he said if
I think of that civilization as being
dead then I can take what we have now
called a forensic new oven I can take it
apart I can look at every portion of it
and I can I can appraise every portion
of it relative to its own view of itself
as portrayed and the other surviving
sources and the example he gave that was
striking to me was a comparison between
the epic of gilgamesh which we still
read in English translation and Akkadian
texts and samples devoted to the
divination by the livers of sheep he
said we have no I can't remember how
many but you know like four or five
cuneiform texts that contain what is
still legible or two still extant of the
Epic of Gilgamesh but we have hundreds
and hundreds of texts that tell how to
tell the future from looking at the
liver of a slaughtered sheep
including clay models of livers so that
you can see and handle in your class now
here's what your cheap little liver will
look like and here on this lobe you'll
find you know such that you know whether
it's going to rain tomorrow and here in
this other lobe you'll find out how long
the King will live things like that and
he said how could I possibly give
greater significance to the epic of
gilgamesh
than to two divination by the liver of
sheep when it was very clear that the
people who actually lived at that time
we're much more interested in divination
by sheep's liver than they were in the
epic of gilgamesh at the same time he
had a a aged mate who was the great
authority on the Sumerians who had been
the earliest of the peoples in ancient
Mesopotamia the man his name was Samuel
Noah Kramer and Kramer's book the
Sumerians is a companion in a sense to
Oppenheimer's book in ancient
Mesopotamia and you look at Kramer what
you find is that in virtually every
chapter and you know sort of in capital
letters in the conclusion of the book he
he specifies what of the Sumerians
remains with us today
what is the heritage of the Sumerians
360 degrees in a circle we get that from
the Sumerians various other things come
from the Sumerians and Oppenheim would
have thought that this was simply
foolish that the idea of that the reason
you study history is to find out what
gifts or Heritage's survive is a
inherently unbalanced view of history
because it's it's looking at yourself
first
and saying Who am I who are we and how
do we relate to this to this era in the
past so so even though he was an ancient
historian I would class Kramer in a
sense as a stakeholder someone who felt
that he was studying the ancient period
in order to illuminate readers about how
that ancient period contributed to
today's civilization today's
intellectual outlooks many of the
historians who deal with the period
before the 20th century have that kind
of viewpoint that say they think that if
they that they can tell a story that
will illuminate something of particular
significance for for people today maybe
it'll be a sort of a macro historical
level like Hegel or marks or Spengler or
Toynbee maybe it will be on a micro
level dealing with just the life of one
person but you have any Austrians who
will who will try to link whatever
they're writing to to today and indeed
if you seek to publish a doctoral
dissertation you'll probably find that
an editor at a press will say this is a
very publishable dissertation could you
add a chapter about how it relates to
9/11 I have for a number of years taught
a graduate seminar called recent trends
in Middle Eastern history or Islamic
history in which we only read books
published since say 2001 or 2002 and
part of the question is would those
books be different if adaptive in not
had it not been for 9/11 it turns out
that 9/11 has affected the scholarship
even for a much earlier period sometimes
its own
in the introduction of the preface say
you know 9/11 was such a shock that it
made me wonder what people felt like
when Mohammed died so let's go back to
know it's sometimes completely facetious
or untenable but but that sense that
somehow there should be a linkages is
often there all right
most stake holding is not of this kind
of abstract fashion most of it has to do
with more specific concerns about the
impact of individuals social groups
political entities economic happenings
as they continue to affect our lives
today which is just fine
but the people who write this history
often have a very clear stake in the in
the whole thing in other words they're
they're drawn to that story because of
who they are and you know where their
family is from sometimes it'll be fairly
palpable in which someone will be
clearly writing history in defense of
his or her people you know wanting to
show that either as an Armenian I am
proving that an Armenian Holocaust
occurred the time of World War one or as
a Turk and proving that no Armenian
Holocaust occurred them or at any other
time so many stakeholders are people who
are they wouldn't say that they are that
they have a program in particular
some of them might some of them might
say very clearly that they are trying to
to establish the truth or recover the
truth or refute a whole packet of lies
told by other historians or to put their
people or their tradition on the map a
map that they've been left out of say
like Kurds or Basques so sometimes it's
a it's that kind of stake holding
sometimes it is in a situational I
mentioned the debate last time the
debate over Herbert Spencer and how
Richard Hofstadter
in 1944 wrote a book on social Darwinism
in America identifying Herbert Spencer
as the arch racist Paragon of social
Darwinism even though the term wasn't
commonly used in the time of Spencer
Spencer probably never heard the term
and certainly would not have identified
with the term and then the argument over
is this something that Hofstadter wrote
simply to correct the record even though
in a sense he was establishing a new
interpretation of early 20th century in
which racism was in existence and he was
putting sort of a form to it or was this
his his left-wing anti-capitalist
politics speaking and that of course is
the point made now by libertarians who
are trying to resurrect Herbert Spencer
as a as a spiritual ancestor of
libertarian anti-socialist thought the
number of historians who have who have
fought for the working class or fought
to suppress the working class each and
the ideas and the vision of the of the
other
now the number is legion people are
drawn to to these stories as I say
sometimes because of their personal
family or religious or national
backgrounds sometimes because of their
ideological commitments sometimes out of
a kind of quixotic desire to set some
sort of record straight but in any case
I think one of the great attractions of
20th century history is that the things
that happened in the 20th century seem
to be so much with us that we can still
we still have time to correct still have
time to to restructure still have time
to mold that story that underlies our
contemporary reality
I recall a discussion we had in an
author's meeting about whether we should
fold World War one and World War two
into a single chapter and call it say
thirty years war in which you had an
interlude of the Great Depression
no firstly the follies of 1920s on the
Great Depression and then you had
another war and we kind of concluded no
that's premature people don't want to
lose World War one in World War two and
yet in the long run when you look back
at the thirty years war of the sixteenth
century or the Hundred Years War in
England in France when you look at back
at other wars that are denominated by by
periods of time you'll find that often
there were substantial interludes of
peace in the midst of those of those
times or that all of the parties were
not fighting all of the time and that
some historian at some point made that
decision
let us fold it all together and call it
the 30 Years War certainly nobody living
through the 30 Years War between
Protestants and Catholics in the
sixteenth century thought they were
living during the 30 Years War it was
they were at war with no Germany or the
Pope or Sweden or some foe but how that
war would ever be designated was was
very unclear so when it comes to world
war one of course World War one was not
called world war one there has been kind
of a search for who was the first person
to call it world war one because the
only way you could call it world war one
is if you were postulating a world war
two by the 1930s you had people who
spent
waiting about a second world war but I
don't know who was the first person to
to use the term World War one if you go
back to the encyclopedias of that time
you'll find it's always called the Great
War
it becomes world war one only in the
aftermath of World War two were in the
event of world war two and so then it
seems likely that there will be another
terminology for example to call it a
thirty-year European Civil War the term
world is very problematic in both wars
there were many parts of the world that
were affected primarily in their trade
relations let us say they were selling
goods to combatants or they were
colonial areas that were providing goods
for combatants most of the people in the
world certainly did not participate in
World War one and even World War two
left significant parts of the world
minimally affected at least by the
direct experience of war and of course
one of the areas of the world that was
least affected by the actual experience
of war was North America the United
States fought in the two wars but nobody
attacked the United States the war
wasn't fought on American soil and
well I shouldn't say nobody attack
United States I guess Pearl Harbor has
to count but but it was not American
mainland so so then you have a question
of why why do we call these world wars
could win could we just as easily talk
about a European civil war a first one
between conservative monarchies and
comparatively dysfunctional
constitutional monarchies or
Democratic monarchies but even then
there are participants who don't fit in
very well to these categories no
Montenegro is one of the allies of the
British and the French and it was
defeated early on and that was the end
of button arrow Bulgaria and Romania
come into the war but in most narratives
the war boils down to what happens in
Europe and in particular what happens on
the Western Front that is say the trench
lines between German and French British
and eventually American forces in France
or what happens on the Eastern Front in
Poland and in the northern part of the
Balkans what happens elsewhere is
usually left out of the narrative in
other words you have a substantial
history of war in East Africa about
during World War one the Germans had a
colony German East Africa what we later
call Tanganyika and that it becomes part
of Tanzania
they had troops in German East Africa
the British sent
a forest to British East Africa to fight
against the Germans and the war went on
there in a not a desultory fashion
because it really was fighting and there
certainly were casualties but in a in a
fashion that was so far removed from the
headlines that we now more or less more
or less forget it but it has it's
interesting points the African Queen is
the movie that comes out of that war and
probably that's what most people know
about that war but the the Germans armed
black African citizens they train them
to be soldiers using the word that was
used earlier by the Italians in their
conquests of Ethiopia and Libya for
native troops called a scurries simply
an Arabic word meaning army or military
so in East Africa the fight was largely
between black Africans and British
forces who use Africans to carry their
their goods they did not give them
weapons but they felt the only way you
could campaign was to have a bunch of
people carrying all of your your camp
Goods and your ammunition and everything
so I had tens of thousands of local
Africans were employed by the British as
Porter's or bearers whereas the Germans
use the Africans for as warriors and
they actually did extremely well there
weren't that many of them but not
surprisingly there knew they knew their
way around the terrain a lot better than
the British did and they had a very good
German commander and that war continued
pretty much through the entire period of
World War one and then was more or less
forgotten
similar things happened elsewhere in
other words forgotten centers of the war
so we end up with this narrative of
machine guns and poison gas and tanks
and the first warplanes Belgium lost
more pilots and training than they did
in combat because the planes had this
reasonable likelihood of simply stopping
the engine stopping and then crashing on
the ground but but that becomes the
story of the war the Japanese occupied
German territories on the Chinese
mainland it's an important fact for
Asian history the by and large that is
the way the story is told since almost
everyone is dead who fought in the war
the issue of being a stakeholder has
pretty much vanished the British Empire
all the empires are gone you'll still
have a few conservative historians who
are eager to recollect how great
European Empire was but by and large
that that notion that there was a stake
in World War one has gone not true of
World War two where the issue of having
a stake in what happened during the war
is still very very much alive now how do
historians handle this one of the most
eminent books on world war one published
in 1962 was a Barbara Tuchman it was
called the guns of August Barbara
Tuchman was a professional journalist
who made her fame as a what we in the
profession consider a lay historian ie a
historian who makes more money than we
do
and she was primarily interested in the
high command of the French and British
armies and how badly they thought about
the preparations for the war and how
badly they prosecuted the war in the
month of August of 1914 when the war
began well it's a very good book it's
very good read completely different
would be a book by French historian a
mark Pharaoh a book called in English
the Great War published in 1969 and
France and then a few years later in
English
Pharaoh as a on the one hand was a man
more on the left and very concerned with
why did the socialist leaders not stop
the war no was this war a great failure
of the of the socialist vision that had
become so important in so many European
countries in the decades leading up to
the war but he also is interested as a
historian of the announced cool in a
kind of social history of the war on our
school meaning that characterized by the
French Journal an all-economy to
associate a civilization for a now ESC
foreshorten so Pharaoh found it
intriguing that when the war broke out
in 1914 there was so much eagerness
enlistment was brisk in virtually every
country
part of it was had to do with the
conviction that the ward the owner over
very quickly which was thought in all
countries part of it was a very strong
patriotism part of it was a palpable
interest in in achieving manhood the
idea that in your generation there this
is the war and if you are not in it you
have missed the the great adventure of
your generation and so you had people
who were not only eager to join the army
but were even more eager to be in a
fighting unit and to be on the front
lines and Diaries and journals talk
about how thrilling it is finally going
to go or finally going to going to
confront the enemy will have our baptism
of fire and so forth and so on
enormous enthusiasm for World War one
and he contrasts that with the zero
level enthusiasm for world war two
except among the Germans who were taking
revenge for the unfair peace that had
been imposed upon them at the end of
World War one and who were fired by a
nationalist ideology that was far more
substantial and effective than anything
ever seen in Europe before though maybe
in the Napoleonic period I'm not sure so
so what how you use these two wars one
people enter into with enthusiasm and
the other people and enter into with
feelings of almost universal dread they
volunteer they want to do the patriotic
thing they want to to be men but there's
no real notion that the war will be fast
and the size of the war is is
anticipated to be massive so he relates
that to a sense of risk and he says that
when you look at you know France which
is his primary point of departure you
look at France after 1910 you see a
society that is in great ferment
intellectually socially politically and
you see indications of a of it being a
society that's very risk prone so he
goes for example to the records of
pawnshops he finds that in the year two
immediately preceding the war the
willingness of people to borrow to pawn
things went up markedly no borrowing of
course being a gamble that the future is
going to be either better or more
lucrative or something will wipe out I
pop the debt and he says that this that
this economic willingness to to to take
on risk led to people being contributed
to people seeing the war as being short
and advantageous to them that they would
come out alive they would be heroes
their country their victorious no even
up to say through 1917 after three years
of war the censors in France prohibit
the new prohibited the newspapers from
using the word peace and it was frowned
on in in conversation if anyone used the
word peace they would be criticized by
other people because the word was
victory
no we're not seeking peace we were
seeking victory and it took a very long
time for people to come around the idea
of that stopping the fighting was what's
what needed to be done so you have a
risk prone population or risk or prone
populations on the eve of World War one
maybe Pharaoh it doesn't speak for all
countries but certainly for for France
wears on the eve of World War two you
have people who have been beaten down by
the Great Depression for for ten years
and they see the war as a continuation
of of the gloom no anticipation of
course that World War two was going to
rescue them from the Great Depression
because of the economic stimulus but
rather that they were in a you know in a
very gloomy mood when they when the war
broke out there are ways to measure this
in the United States having to do with
studying automatic samples when I'm not
going to have laid that on you once
before I'm not going to go into it again
but it's when you can see very clear my
certain quantitative measures of names
you know how people reacted to a world
war one world war two the depression and
so far the song a very interesting
phenomenon so pharaoh was taking a sort
of but nowadays we call a structural
approach structuralism was very much in
at that time late 60s into the 70s the
idea that when you looked at at big
events you should be looking at
underlying structures
structuralism kind of faded in the 1990s
even in the 1980s even though it had
been vogue --is-- in many fields
anthropology religion folklore history
the notion that the job of the scholar
is to find underlying structures took a
hit that it hasn't really recovered from
and that hip was in part supported by
the work of Edward Sayid and the people
who were so enamored of his work that
said that you know when you think when
you have a Frenchman who thinks that he
is understanding the deep structure of
how Amazon tribes people operate that is
an Orientalism that is a fabrication it
is something that the scholars inventing
for his or her personal edification and
consciously or unconsciously in
inventing it abetting the imperialist
capitalist structure of things and we
shouldn't do that anymore we should do
something else like we should spend our
time tearing apart the work of the past
generations of scholars so post
structuralism came in which which was
more interested in the examination of
the of the discourse of the the way
words are used and strung together in
scholarly works than in ferreting out
new archives or new bodies of of
information
one of the products of this I would
argue is that as we come down to today
some of the older ideas of trying to
structure history have given way to a
growing interest in what is generally
called history from below where you
don't try and figure anything out
anything out you simply try to assemble
and juxtapose bits of information or
texts that relate to somebody not
anybody of any importance it was
somebody maybe the first well-known text
of the sort was to return to Martin
guerre written by Natalie Zemon Davis of
Princeton 30 years ago there abouts
there have been a number of books
recently that used this technique of of
looking at people of no significance and
saying we won't assert anything about
the overall structure of what's going on
in the history that they are part of
we'll simply look at their lives in that
history in this vein there is a book
that was just published last week and
that has been very well reviewed and
that I'm now 60% of the way through and
my Kindle my historian named Peter
Englund is called the sorrow and the
beauty and it is a history of World War
one sounds like a movie yes I
when I worked for CBS once they the
polling person said that whenever they
pull the title of a movie for popularity
they always test it against the title
the fire in the wind because apparently
that is always the most attractive movie
title ever but nobody's ever made a
movie called that so they will
something's well how would you compare
Tower Heist to the fire in the wind
Sarah I want to go fire the whip no
where's that showing Tower Heist you
know saw it last night wasn't very good
so it does sound like a movie title but
but what Englund has done is quite
fascinating he has assembled a group of
20 or so individuals
none of them of any fame or any
notoriety who wrote journals or Diaries
or letters or whose names appeared in
dispatches and reports during World War
one and he has told he tells the story
chronologically so that you have you
know you know January 17th
you know Maurice Ron Paul and his unit
are told to go to route to replace a
unit at 0.32 one on the line at very
done and then he describes how they go
there and they're going under the orders
that you will replace the unit that is
already there and you will hold that
piece of the line until you have lost
three-quarters of your amount then
you'll be relieved by another unit and
that's exactly what happens they go
there they have German bombardments a
machine-gun fire and when they lose
three quarters of their personnel
another unit comes to be slaughtered in
their place
it's an incredibly grim grim book it has
at least five of the 20 or so speakers
are women
people who are in nurse or ambulance
cores or simply who are simply refugees
who are caught up in the war and write
about it it includes people in the
German army people in Russian army
people in the Ottoman army people in the
French army Italian army very little
about the English army but some I
haven't gotten to the point where the
Americans come yet and yet so I don't
know what the Americans will be like and
when you read this it very artfully put
together
I mean think of a Ken Burns documentary
in which and you have you never hear
anything about grant orally or Stonewall
Jackson you just hear about private
soldiers or noncommissioned officers who
are in the lower ranks but woven
together with the same sort of of skill
and of course you come away with a very
different picture of this war as the war
comes out in this account certain things
are striking one is it was incredibly
boring most people did nothing most of
the time they waited for something to
happen there's some poor soul who serves
on the the British on the German
battleship the Helgoland and he wants to
be in a great naval battle and his ship
never goes to war he finally has a
battle his ship fires sixty five shells
is hit by one shell and then they go
back into
pour it again and all of his stories
about how frustrating it is that he
hasn't been in battle other people will
have a very different approach to battle
someone who never volunteers for
anything in the French army hoping that
he will never be selected for anything
dangerous and tries his best to avoid
ever being in a battle or another guy in
American an Italian American who goes to
Italy to serve in the Italian Army who
as he approaches his first battle
suddenly is seized right by the idea
that he doesn't want to kill anybody
a phenomenon that's pretty well tested
in other Wars and so he goes into battle
and he fires his gun cuz he has to when
he fires it into the air so he won't
hurt anybody thinking well maybe he
won't be hurt in return so then he
finally is hurt in return and ends up in
the hospital where he goes crazy and
thinks that he has been destined by God
to solve the war so they put him in a in
an asylum and eventually ship him back
to the United States in other words
these are not heroic people some of them
are zealots some of them are are not and
they're all undergoing boredom and
hardship and the ubiquity of dead people
is one of the most striking things there
are dead people all over the place and
we look at the grand numbers of how many
people were killed in World War one and
and we think well that's a huge number
of people and what is very clear in
these accounts is that you know half a
dozen of those who were killed are right
over there and you can still see their
faces and their bodies stink and so the
horror of the whole thing is very very
powerful
everyone is know seeing this as a as a
Holocaust as a just a vast waste of life
or at least that is the impression you
get on reading it particularly strong of
course for the nurses and the ambulance
people who have to deal specifically
with the wounded wounds are described in
great detail how there would be special
hospitals established out in the woods
for men whose faces have been shot away
because they were so gruesome to look at
they didn't want them to be where
anybody could see them and of course the
refusal of all the governments to
release any figures about about losses
and so on
so it's a very powerful book yeah
because there are people who find
glorious moments and you know there is
elet's there are people for whom this is
a magnificent experience the
the book I compare it with is one that
none of you should read I can't
recommend it although I read it but I
have very low taste and that is a
recently published book world wars ed
which is the story of the same way the
story from below of the memories of what
happened during the great world war
against the zombies no Zedd is for
zombie where the zombies almost destroy
the entire human population and they are
there defeated and so now this is a
historian looking back and saying what
happened in the great war against the
zombies it's not such a bad book
actually a zombie books go it's why I
say it's better than Pride and Prejudice
and Zombies
but but Pride and Prejudice and Zombies
is actually pretty good
no thank you
so the opportune moment but one of the
interesting comparisons is that the
author of World War Zed is particularly
interested in conveying the horror of
the great zombie war you know the zombie
staggering about and limbs falling off
and horrendously wounded and they're
biting you and so forth and so on
and Peter Englund book is far more
horrifying in talking about the reality
of war and it it it's interesting
because we've had a vogue in this
country for the last 25 years or so
maybe a little longer for a
post-apocalyptic fiction whether in
movies or in or in novels or in comic
books
and there simply aren't enough dead it's
it's it's striking that you you have
people are trying to imagine most of the
humans on the planet dying of something
you know what plague or poison gas or
alien invasion or zombie itis or
whatever it is but but the dead just
don't show up very much
whereas in World War one
it's the ubiquity of the Dead and the
horribleness of the loss of life that
comes through in these snippets of
visualization so I find myself wondering
well does Peter Englund have a stake in
this is there some non-structural
non-meta historical non geopolitical
lesson he's trying to to bring across is
this fundamentally an anti Holocaust
book or book asking people to to look at
the loss of life everywhere irrespective
of national commitment or ideology or
station in life and see that that the
actuality of this kind of conflict is
vastly worse than the imagining of the
conflict I call number of years ago
reading a book called world war three
that was a visualization of British
general of what would happen when the
Soviets invaded Central Europe and and
it had that characteristic of no dead
people and so I was thinking well
is this is this part of a generalized
fantasies a non-jewish specific sense of
the horror of mass killing and have we
gotten to a point where we find this you
know peculiarly horrifying and if so is
it something that's been reinforced by
the American actions in Iraq or
Afghanistan where we hear so much about
civilian casualties and so forth and so
on
I don't know but I think that Peter
England while writing a really really
deeply moving book is a stakeholder in
some sense and it's saying something
about how we look at at this sort of
thing today in a sort of post
ideological post geopolitical
post-holocaust world I'll make one final
remark I chose to be a medieval
historian specializing in the Muslim
Arab world I made that decision at the
end of my freshman year in college and
that's what I trained to do and one of
the things that was most important to me
then and ever since is that I wanted to
be a historian who had no stake in the
outcome I never expected to teach about
either the modern Middle East or the
modern world I was interested in
knitting socks or exporting rickshaws or
inventing a way to pollinate the vanilla
plant and
in some ways what you hope to do as a
historian or what do you think you are
good at is historian often gets
overtaken by the by the world that
you're living in so as we go on to more
20th century history in the next final
three weeks I'm gonna try and act like a
stakeholder but I'm very dubious that I
really care tightly